we have five  children's hospitals in the united  states  telling girls  that they can be boys  at seventy thousand dollars a pop in a  surgery that has 67 percent complication  rate that will kill me from infection  that i can't sue on  butchering a generation of children  because nobody's willing to talk about  anything from nugent  who is the true hero of the film in my  opinion we get total  openness and uh honesty raw  gut-wrenching honesty  from the other side we get defensiveness  lies accusations  one side wants us all to talk about this  right like let's talk about this  the other side wants to talk wants to be  the one talking while we shut up  and they'll do anything they can to shut  us up  but they will fail and they already have  because this film isn't going anywhere